hey what's going on it's bill bird it's
time for the thursday afternoon just
before friday monday morning podcast and
i'm just checking in on you
seeing how you doing getting through
august
are you gonna get solar panels
i looked up one goddamn thing on solar
panels and then everything that i look
at
on the internet now to the side has uh
you know solar panels you know
unfortunately one of my great friends in
life passed away this week
and i was looking up some flowers a
floral arrangement for him
because i can't go back to the funeral
with all this [ __ ] covid [ __ ] and uh
as i'm sitting there
fighting back tears trying to find a new
england patriot
floral arrangement for my buddy that i'm
getting a [ __ ] advertisement for
solar panels on the side
like like that's what i'm thinking about
you know lost one of my great friends
but you know
i really could be be a little more
responsible the way i'm using the energy
around my house
[ __ ] relentless relentless
advertising yes so
uh the great wayne previty um
i met him on my third stand-up show
ever um we were
at this bar called uh kelly's
in north reading massachusetts
at that point it was my third my first
spot i did a you know
a talent show find boston's funniest
college student
at knicks comedy stop that was my first
one then i did the open mic
night um at st did now defunct stitches
comedy club
and i did okay on both of those
and then um
then i did kelly's that was the first
time
i ever bombed and i remember uh it was
jack lynch
it was his room and i was supposed to do
like five minutes and i got to like two
and a half minutes of not making anybody
laugh
and um i literally said on the mic i
said jack i'm bailing i'm bailing and
and all the comics went ah like they
didn't want me
to quit i don't know what the [ __ ] is in
my throat right now
is it the pollen so anyway
um he ended up going up that night it
was the first time i saw him and
i don't know what it was i just became
friends with him and
through all the [ __ ] ups and downs of
this business you know
living in the same cities living on
opposite coasts i just never lost touch
with the guy we always [ __ ]
called each other and just talked sports
and all of that
and um yeah man i cannot i was one of
the big
you know as many friends as i lost uh it
was a huge shock
and um yeah i'm just gonna miss him
that's all i can say
i'll tell you a great i'll tell you a
couple of great wayne preview stories
are this one is not my story
this is actually one that mike clark
from giggles told me
so anyways mike and his and lenny
were in san diego and they were doing a
charity golf tournament and
uh you know knocking the old golf ball
around or whatever and then
you know they look at the patriots
schedule and lo and behold they're
playing the san diego
churches at [ __ ] jack murphy stadium
so they go well they're playing tomorrow
why don't we just hang around we'll go
to the games they say yeah like all
right cool so
you know the clarks are [ __ ] royalty
in boston
you know they hit up pop craft robert
crap and he goes yeah [ __ ] come on
down watch it in my
uh my owner's suite
so they go down to that [ __ ] dump of
a stadium that they never [ __ ]
repaired but the chargers still
shouldn't have left
i mean how nice does it have long as the
field's nice what the [ __ ] are you
bitching about
um still don't understand that move
still do not understand that move but
anyway that's how sports franchises are
unless you buy me a new stadium once
every 30 years we're gonna [ __ ] leave
although that was 50. um
so anyway so they go to the game and
they're they're sitting there they're
watching the game and as always the
chargers probably had a chance to beat
us and then for some reason
took a dumb penalty or whatever dumb
[ __ ] that they did uh
so they're watching the game and all of
a sudden mike notices
uh robert craft with a big smile on his
face and kind of laughing
he's like what are you laughing at he
goes look at that [ __ ] he goes look at
that he didn't say that [ __ ] guy
that's how i always said he goes look at
that guy over there
and they looked into the crowd and there
was this like lone patriot fan going
nuts
with a bunch of you know charger fans
around him he didn't give a [ __ ]
and robert kraft was laughing go look at
that guy
we we need fans like this guy this guy
is crazy right so mike looks down
and he sees and he goes holy [ __ ] i know
that guy and it was wayne previtty
and he had gone to the game i think with
one or two of his other friends and he
was he was going
so [ __ ] nuts cheering the patriots
that the owner of the patriots
spotted him in the crowd
so mike ends up yelling down he goes way
way and he turns around he's like hey
mike how you doing he goes come on up
come on up so he [ __ ] goes
up there and he meets bob craft
and he's just like a guy she just same
way i did he just [ __ ] loved the guy
he goes you're such a great fan we need
more fans like you
and wayne as always was totally humble
and was just talking to patriots
and you know and then within like five
seconds
or whatever a minute of talking to him
he j
wayne is such a fan that he doesn't give
a [ __ ] i mean he
cares that he's meeting robert kraft but
he's right back into the game
and continued to go nuts in the owner's
suite like he was sitting in the crowd
and um i just know that robert kraft
i just seemed like he had the same
feelings about you know that same vibe
that he put out and wayne of course
being wayne
you know didn't [ __ ] try to get
robert kraft's number
never hit him up for tickets didn't try
to pitch him a [ __ ] patriots reality
show
you know it's just how he was and um
i don't know i actually drove around
hollywood looking at all the places
that we hung out all the gyms
you know i was a member of a couple of
gyms with him the only time i ever put
up 225 in my life which was a big thing
for somebody who came of age in the 80s
she wanted to have the two [ __ ]
plates the 245s on each side right and
his thing is he wanted to put up what is
it 315
because he goes when you had three
plates that's when the bar starts to
bend a little bit so
you know now my shoulders paid for all
of that but
um we used to have a great time down
there we used to go to the uh
the frolic room there was a uh a sports
bar called big wangs
that used to be on kawanga it's now i
think moved up to noho
he was a staple there uh
the laugh factory just all of these
places i just went around and visited i
drove by this bar i remember one night i
mouthed off to this guy i mean this guy
got into it
and uh one of those guys that looks like
he's your size until he stands up and
the [ __ ] guy was like an oak tree and
i was like oh boy
swing once and cover um but
wayne like a [ __ ] pitbull jumped
right up
wayne was 6'3 got in between the two of
us back the guy
down and uh i never forgot that i mean
that's a big thing if your buddies
because i don't even know if wayne would
have beat this guy but like he was
willing to take a [ __ ] ass kicking
for me
and um yeah i can't i cannot believe
absolutely in like a state of shock and
all i can say
is a little public service announcement
here for all the guys listen is go to
the [ __ ] doctor every year and get
yourself checked out
all right um i have lost
i've i've lost almost
uh well over 50 people i mean i'm also
older
52 but like i have lost three friends
this year
two heart attacks and a stroke and
all you know late 40s early 50s and
out of all the comics that i've known
i've known like upwards of 40 comics
that have died only one has been a woman
and she died
of cancer and
[Music]
i'm not saying every other guy didn't
you know died of something preventable
but it seems like
half of them if they went to the doctor
would still be around and their loved
ones would still have them
so um you know i'm also talking to
myself i'm gonna go get the old ticker
checked out to make sure i'm all right
because i even had a couple of friends
that had my build
and um either i don't know
just something genetic or in the family
whatever but with modern medicine
they go in there they see what the
problem is and
you know nine times out of ten they can
[ __ ] fix it
and your loved ones still have you so uh
there you go
take the advice so don't take the advice
but i
you know feeling this [ __ ] pain this
week i
felt like i had to say something all
right
all right rest in peace rest in peace
wayne previty aka vinnie age
um all right uh
let's try to spin out of that solar
panels death of a friend
into uh nhl playoff hockey how about
those [ __ ] bruins
um how about those bruins huh they end
up winning in overtime
um i actually i missed every second of
the game i thought the [ __ ] game
came on at 11 a.m
uh pacific time because it was such a
weird time
for the game because you know tampa bay
and columbus had that
five overtime thriller
85 saves for corpus sallo i mean just
unbelievable you stop 85 pucks and you
still lose the game like the playoffs
has just been crazy um
so i i was taking my daughter out
um we've been quarantining with this
other family and our daughters
hang out once a week so i was over there
and then of course i start getting all
these text messages
um you know did you you're watching the
game this is [ __ ] unbelievable blah
blah blah and i'm like and i'm looking
at my
my watch and was just like what what are
we talking about it's [ __ ]
10 30 in the morning and then that's
what i figured out that you know
i don't know the game started early but
i did watch the uh
the tampa bay columbus game and i've
been keeping up on all of this stuff
with
my busy home life here um some of the
scores
around the way sorry if this podcast
sucks i am a little distracted with all
the [ __ ] that happened in my life
for the last couple of days
um see where the hell am i
bruins play again today
um the [ __ ]
all the way back to eight six eight four
what is what is with the [ __ ] goddamn
thing it's going both ways on me here
eight nine round okay round one here we
are all right bruins went four to three
the [ __ ] calgary flames keep cruising
along with luke
three to two over the [ __ ] dallas
stars
uh lightning beat the blue jackets in
five overtimes
golden knights beat the blackhawks
who've been hot man
lost the first game um bruins obviously
i just said oh
double overtime bruins uh bergeron
beat the hurricanes caps lose to the
islanders
avalanche three nothing and then the
flyers
the number one seed beat the hated habs
thank you
philadelphia flyers you still got you
still is this is this best three out of
five by the way
i have no idea what's going on or is
this the this is the actual you gotta
win four games
and the canucks beat the defending
stanley cup champion st
louis blues so uh i don't know what kind
of team the blues have but if they have
the team like last year uh
that's a great thing for vancouver to
win early you got to beat the blues
within five or six games because by
game seven they've beaten you physically
down to their [ __ ] talent level
which was how it used to work back in
the day
um hey you got you're better than us all
right we're just going to beat the [ __ ]
out of you
um anyway so i'm going to watch the game
today i'm gonna try to
do the best i can and then i have a
little bit of a little [ __ ]
announcement here
uh did you enjoy king of staten island
did you see did you try to watch king of
staten island you were like 20 bucks
[ __ ] this uh you can actually uh
own king of staten island on digital or
blu-ray
on august 25th all streaming platforms
whatever the [ __ ] going on
has a bunch of bonus footage
um i know you know just from the some of
the stuff that i saw
the other actors do in the firehouse i
can't imagine all the stuff that all the
great stuff that judd apatow is going to
have out there for you
it's on august 25th a great movie
during a a difficult time in these the
new normal whatever the hell you're
supposed to say it's uh
it's a great comedy with a lot of hat
starring the amazing pete davidson
and the legendary marisa tomei steve
buscemi i mean
it's got a lot of talent in there and
then a big red mustache
comes in every once in a while um
so anyway um oh god what a [ __ ]
brutal week man
what a brutal week so i actually found a
place that does a patriots floral
arrangement because i can't make it back
for the funeral which is really [ __ ]
bothering me
um so i don't know i'm gonna figure out
how the [ __ ] that works it's weird you
can just order it online they also have
a phone number i just don't trust that i
just
write this [ __ ] i i send somebody a
[ __ ] message
and then they just go ahead and do it i
just
you know the same way i [ __ ] hate
backup cameras
you know what's funny i i i've gotten so
used to the backup camera in my car when
i drive my old truck i start backing up
and i'm not even looking
i mean it's just for a split second i'm
like what the [ __ ] am i doing and then i
look over my shoulder
and what i love about my truck is i look
over my shoulder and i can actually
see you know because i used to be able
to back up a car i used to be [ __ ]
great at it
and with the video cameras i suck and
when i look over my shoulder
um you can't see anything out the back
window cause there's a backup camera
which totally affects the design now
so i just use the side once i use the
side mirrors i [ __ ] crush it again
um that's the only way i know how to get
out of my driveway
i gotta use the side mirrors that's
stupid
starts doing that because a leaf on a
fern
is near my car and i'm like what the
[ __ ] am i gonna hit what
am i gonna hit and it's literally it's
like a [ __ ] a grasshopper
jumped on the side of the [ __ ] car i
feel like a cat or a toddler ran out
behind me
um so anyways
uh dean delray
has always hooked me up with a [ __ ]
uh i've been redoing my little uh
podcast studio here and i got an
old-school
[ __ ] hi-fi
that has like uh am fm
radio and all of that type of [ __ ] i'm
gonna hook up my uh
my turntable to it i got these sick ass
speakers i'll have the names of all the
[ __ ] that i have
um you know when we get it all hooked up
tonight
and the first song i'm playing of course
you gotta play back in black
uh i gotta hear the way this sounds and
and dean was literally telling me he's
like you're not even able to turn this
thing up a quarter of the way
this whole [ __ ] office is gonna be
vibrating so i'm pretty excited about
that
uh as far as like a nice old-school
uh thing to have it was such a big deal
when
you were growing up you know if you
bought a new stereo
am fm stereo dual cassette
you know and then the big thing was you
know if if the
when you ejected the uh
the cd like how it came out the ones
that came out
gently like silk we're [ __ ] that's
when you that's
literally how you judge the stereo if it
came out nice and slow
if it [ __ ] spit the tape out like
somebody gave it the heimlich maneuver
you knew you had some piece of [ __ ] that
you got at radio shack
we used to go to um what the [ __ ] was
the name of the stereo store these to be
like like
having a stereo is such a big [ __ ]
deal that at the south shore plaza
in braintree massachusetts right across
from uh
what was it hobby town or kb toy and
hobby i can't even remember right across
the way was a [ __ ]
stereo like this just
it was like uh where don cheetah worked
in boogie nights it was just
you went in and they had all of these
giant [ __ ] speakers
and they had all these cool looking guys
that were selling [ __ ] stereos
um i mean it was like considered like a
really badass job and that [ __ ] maul
back in the day was just all
ron burgundy colors the whole [ __ ]
maul was like brown
it had these these plastic this light
plastic
brown um
like flooring like the tile and they had
these these round circles that were
probably the size of a silver dollar
and it was brown everything was brown
there was a place pewter pot
that somehow sold muffins that then
became like a sit-down restaurant and
actually had like uh
meals that you could eat a full meal
then you get like a muffin for dessert
and everything in there was like the
tables weighed like eight thousand
pounds it made out of like [ __ ]
redwoods or some [ __ ]
and um i've been back to that mall a
couple of times since they redid it now
it's like two floors
they went the completely the other way
it's like all [ __ ] white
and bright and all of this [ __ ] um
yeah back in the day it was one level
you went in and you go into the stereo
store
and they'd always tell you you know
don't judge the speaker by the size of
it man you got to judge it by the sound
man
so i'm looking forward to having that
[ __ ] uh all hooked up
out here in my lonely office so i can
listen to some [ __ ] music all by my
lonesome
um other than that i don't really have
any [ __ ] news for you just a
devastating emotional
uh week for me and uh
you know i've been flying a couple times
a week doing the helicopter thing and i
almost didn't fly
on tuesday and then my wife was like nah
wayne wouldn't want you to go
you know so i was like all right so i
went out there and then i actually did
really well like we've been doing like
all these auto rotations and [ __ ]
and um so i got those things back to
where i
i was before i took this long layoff and
now we started getting into like the
advanced auto rotations
which is basically where you're right
over your spot
and you bleed off all your air speed
obviously keeping you while you're
keeping your main rotor system
uh maintenance main road rpms going and
then uh we were doing the [ __ ] where
if you didn't have uh you know once you
bled it all the way back how to then
nose it over
um get your speed back and then go into
the flare i got everything down except
for the flare i always want to pull the
collective up just out of muscle memory
like i'm doing a fast stop
you know and uh we've been doing that
and we actually started doing ones where
you actually were
you auto started doing auto rotation you
actually go back
start like going backwards to get back
over your spot and then nose it over and
then come back down it was [ __ ] wild
but i'm actually starting to be able to
feel it
it's really exciting because that's the
number one
fear is the uh an engine failure and am
i going to be able to
know what to do and um
you'd be surprised the amount of people
that get their license and they just
don't practice those things enough i
don't know why the [ __ ] you would do
that to yourself but i do it all
the goddamn time and i just want i want
to be able to just like
you know put that thing into a [ __ ]
parking space
backwards right over the spot
and um you know
and then eventually i don't know if i
ever start touring again
i'm trying to find a couple of people to
go in on something that has a little
more uh
weight to it i'd like a fully
articulated three-bladed you know
basically an a-star
or something like that an a-star
essentially
but a-stars are kind of weird though
because when you auto when you want to
rotate those things i i heard when
you're on a rotation when you
hit the ground you still have to slide a
little bit which is weird to me
you know i actually
know a guy that knows a guy that just
had a an engine failure in that
in one of those things and he and he put
it on top of a [ __ ] building right on
the goddamn pad
total stud just [ __ ] landed the thing
and then had to run out and go do a gig
and just jumped in a car and then did
the gig and he was halfway through the
gig
and then he got like six to his stomach
and had to go to the bathroom and
[ __ ] puke because he hadn't
emotionally dealt with
that he almost died because he had this
gig he had to go play
it's [ __ ] wild why do i do this [ __ ]
i don't know
i don't know um
i don't know i don't know my [ __ ]
brain's all over the place let me uh
i'm trying to hold it together here let
me uh let me read a couple of the uh
advertisements here all right everybody
look who it is
whoop there it is whoop
w h w-h-o-p uh whiskey hotel oscar oscar
papa whoop is a fitness wearable
that provides personalized insights on
the performance of your sleep
how recovered you are and how much
stress you put on your body throughout
the day from both your workouts in the
normal stressors of life
whoop has been using uh respite
using respiratory rate to help members
detect potential signs of illness
before other symptoms develop um
jesus christ can it detect you know
heart attacks and strokes that'd be
amazing
uh whoop has recently i imagine you can
use a lot of this information towards
that um
and give it to your doctor uh whoop has
recently
partnered with you know i'm gonna
[ __ ] i got two i'm an old dad i'm
gonna get one of these things
has recently partnered with strava so
you can now
upload your activities automatically
from whoop to strava with recovery sleep
and other metrics
whoop tracks all four stages of sleep
slow wave rem
light and awake awake
that's part of sleep the [ __ ] is that is
that
sleeping with your eyes open uh and can
tell you
what does that mean you sleep walking
through life and can tell you how much
sleep you've gotten down to the minute
their sleep tracking has also officially
received
third party validation
um sleep coach i'd like to know what the
third party validation is
uh sleep coach is custom tailored to you
and calculates your sleep need based on
a variety of data points
with the ability to set levels to peak
perform or
peak comma perform or get by
depending on what is planned for the
following day
why would you ever choose anything but
peak
you must be out boozing uh strain coach
is a feature that allows you to plan
your workout to hit your target exertion
level plan the the
workout that your body is truly ready
for check your progress in real time and
finish your workout when whoop
has let you know that you've pushed your
body hard enough
uh woop has a has a really smart
charging system where their battery pack
slides right on top of the straps so you
never have to take it off to charge
you won't ever have to worry about
losing a night of sleep or missing a
workout
okay whoop is offering 15 off when you
use the code bur at checkout go to
woop.com w-h-o-o-p
dot com and enter the code bur b-u-r-r
just save 15
sleep better recover faster and train
smarter with woop today
all right ah look who it is everybody
it's fun time sports are back
and that could mean one thing draftkings
uh the hits really keep on coming from
one
mma event to the next this is
fascinating to me they grow in
excitement and anticipation
ufc 252 is no different
uh with two sports two of the sport's
most respected fighters
sleeping uh stepping into the octagon
this weekend
there's no better place to get on in on
all the action with dr
then with draftkings the leader in one
time one day
fantasy sports jesus bill uh for this
weekend's fight draftkings
is offering new users a free shot at one
million dollars in total prizes
do you haven't tried it yet fantasy mma
is easy to play you just pick six
fighters fighting out of the red corner
uh stay under the salary cap
that's my favorite thing there you pick
six fighters you stay under the salary
cap anybody can
pick six favorites now you gotta be a gm
are you gonna be top heavy like the
toronto maple leafs
you can score six goals but [ __ ] give
up seven
how are you gonna do it um where the
hell am i uh stay under the salary cap
and pile up points for advances
takedowns and more
there's no better way to put on your mma
knowledge
uh to the test to put your mma knowledge
to the test than to compete for a free
shot
at one million dollars in total prizes
but if mma isn't for you don't worry
draftkings is offering plenty of fantasy
contests
for all the sports uh that have returned
to action
new this year draftkings just launched a
best ball contest for
football i don't even know what that
means
if you aren't familiar with best balls
simply head to the app now and check it
out look at them anticipating the
question
download the draftkings app now and use
promo code burr to get a free shot at
one million dollars in total prizes for
this weekend's
ufc 252 contest that's promo code burr
to get a free
shot at one million dollars with your
first deposit only at draftkings
minimum five dollar deposit required
eligibility restrictions apply see
draftkings.com
for details you know one of the jokes
i've been saying about the passing of uh
my buddy wayne preview he was the
biggest patriots fan
i ever met i don't think i don't think
he in the 28 years that i knew that guy
he never missed a [ __ ] game ever he
watched every
single [ __ ] game from the very
beginning to the very end
um all the way up to pre bill parcells
drew bledsoe so i mean he was there for
was it mcpherson or rod rust i forget
who was coaching when
victor kayam you know and we were just
the doormats of the league
um and uh
you know he just watched all of them and
i was joking with the buddy as you do
when a buddy dies i was joking with a
friend of mine
i just said you know what i don't think
that i don't think that he could take
seeing tom brady in in a tampa bay
buccaneers
uniform broken-hearted that he's gone so
um anyway sorry to keep bringing up him
but
the [ __ ] you gonna do that's what's on
my mind um
yep and with that i think that's gonna
be it here everybody sorry about the uh
you know the sort of frazzled podcast
here today
uh what else what else um
i'm really chomping at the bit i'm
looking for some stage time i gotta i
have to find uh
it seems like these shows have been safe
the minimal amount of people there and
uh
i know the comedy store has been doing
some stuff
i know that uh down in san diego they've
had a few shows
you know so i'm gonna try to figure out
some place to get on stage because i'm
going [ __ ] nuts
i'm really going [ __ ] nuts here so
anyway that is the podcast
um for this thursday afternoon um
please listen to uh the music here that
the great andrew andrew
themlist picks out and then we'll have a
bonus episode of a
uh thursday afternoon just before friday
monday morning podcast from uh i don't
know a couple years back or whatever
and uh once again man once again
rest in peace wayne prebitty i just
really
from the bottom of my heart i could not
have had a better friend all right
you guys have a great weekend i'll talk
hey what's going on it's bill burr and
it's the monday morning podcast for
monday
august 13 2012.
how the hell are you how's it going
august 13th can you believe it only
three more weeks of the summer
right but thanks to global warming you
can still get a tan
right through the second week of october
you know
enjoy it folks this is the golden age of
global warming
you know this is before polar bear swims
up to your [ __ ] apartment
you know all those
fires in the middle of the country who
cares those are flyover states right
that's just our food supply
um i've always thought it was funny the
way people make fun of those states
you know because they don't have what a
water slide and a giant [ __ ]
skyscraper
all of a sudden they don't count yeah
all they're doing is [ __ ] you know
providing nourishment for everyone in
the state i'm sorry everyone in the
nation
all they're doing is growing enough food
to feed the world but we don't
right and i think that's a good thing i
think a good thing that we don't feed
the world
there's too many [ __ ] people and
that's why the polar ice caps are
melting it has nothing to do with v8
engines
okay there's too many goddamn people so
what i'm gonna do
eventually in 25 years when i get famous
enough
is i'm going to put together my own
collection
of musicians and we're going to do we
aren't the world
all right
[Laughter]
we aren't the world you're not a
responsibility
i'm sorry you don't have an apple tree
so go [ __ ] yourself
there's too many people taking shits
every day and it's [ __ ] up the world
for me and you all right
we got more [ __ ] that's how it worked
out all right you get the idea
you know i wonder who that would
actually return that [ __ ] phone call
that getting [ __ ] maniac from was in
that movie heat
i bet he would the guy was doing porns
now oh yeah
god i mean that guy just once i want to
have an orgasm like that and be [ __ ]
going
oh jesus like he was
like somebody kicked you in the nuts um
anyways you wouldn't believe this right
now the way this is going in where i'm
saying don't save the world
okay let him go that's how i would run
for office
excuse me um non-senator burr i was
wondering
what you thought about the problems
in croatia rwanda band
uh yeah i don't really know i don't give
a [ __ ] i mean i think it's terrible but
uh you know
you know the more people die the more
fresh air for us that's how we look at
it you know as long as it isn't anybody
with with our flag on their shoulder i
think that that would be okay
that's appalling that's a realistic
outlook lady
okay you want to be on the ship that's
sailing towards surviving
i suggest you change your attitude next
question you over there with the striped
tie
you know the other guy with the stripe
type and the receding hair
yes you i'm not answering that go [ __ ]
yourselves
it's a figure of speech jesus christ um
i actually have a giant announcement
giant a big for me
okay i have a big announcement for me
all right i'm pregnant um i just found
out and i'm really excited for myself
no i i um i
i've been telling you guys that i
recorded a stand-up special
in the wonderful district of columbia
back in march
and ever since then you guys have been
asking me hey bill
when is that special coming out well on
this week's podcast
i will be announcing when my special
comes out
but not right now for some stupid reason
i'm gonna wait until the end
just like one of those dumb shows on tv
you know
where all you need is one piece of
[ __ ] information they just try to
drag it out
so they can get in eight minutes of
advertising and somebody can have a
yacht
right now i'm [ __ ] with you i'm gonna
do it right out of the gate
that's how i do it because i'm not
playing the game man
um okay my new special
is entitled you people are all the same
and it will
premiere exclusively on netflix
it's the only place you're going to be
able to see it is netflix
why do you ask because i love those guys
they show my entire special
it's unedited it captures the exact
level of ignorance
that that i wanted to put out there i
love those guys so it's going to be
premiering exclusively on netflix
um this thursday august 16th at 6
00 a.m pacific time
so for all you grumpy people out there
that's 9 a.m pacific time
all right it'll be available to all
netflix members in the united states
canada ireland and
the united kingdom well isn't ireland
part of the
uk
hey nia isn't ireland part of the uk or
at least northern ireland is right i
just lost everyone in [ __ ]
and is making a face we went over there
we learned this
we went on the double decker bus tour
and they told us what the lady
and the king owned right remember that
it's the united kingdom as far as my
understanding is
is england wales scotland
and uh in northern ireland
that's what it is it's northern ireland
my apologies to everybody keeping it
real
in southern ireland as opposed to all
those sellouts in northern ireland who
are just
fine with that big eared douche telling
you what to do
is that what you're telling me how many
beer glasses am i gonna get thrown at my
[ __ ] head if i ever go back
if i go up to belfast anyways i'm just
[ __ ] with you guys over there
all right hang on a second what'd you
say
eastern and i'm talking about the united
states
oh 9 a.m eastern oh did i say pacific
twice i'm sorry
well either way i was just talking about
the united states with those times you
know why
because we aren't the world
so i'm really excited that it's also
going to be in canada
ireland and the uk um because uh i go to
those places
and when i go to those places only three
people show up so
uh maybe this will be able to uh as the
dollar collapses
i'll be able to uh go to places where
there's other currency
and i'll get to start this journey all
over again nia
remember when you met me and i was still
on a futon
that's actually true it is true
okay so my new special you people are
all the same it's going to premiere
exclusively on netflix this thursday
august 16th
6 a.m pacific 9 a.m uh eastern
and uh what's the difference what's the
difference between here and uh
was it five hours to england uh you guys
figure it out with your [ __ ] metric
system
you know what is somebody somebody
actually summed up soccer for me
finally how the hell did he describe it
i was saying why americans don't like
soccer this guy said to me
he goes we already have this game over
here we call it hockey
you know except it's way faster there's
hitting
it's fighting it's phenomenal and it's
funny that he said that because whenever
i watch soccer
the the the stuff that appeals to me is
is that it is like hockey with the
offsides and that type of [ __ ] but i
don't get it why the defenseman just
gets to stop
and then all of a sudden i'm off sides
you know
keep running you douche you know what
i'm trying to do like that's that's your
defense
you don't even have to knock me on my
ass you just stop it's just a terrible
game
you know we have arms people
use them would you watch a sport if all
you used was your arms
and you didn't use your legs and
everyone was just standing there or
maybe sitting on the ground
or maybe just in one of those craftmatic
beds like just throwing balls to one
another
oh my god did i just describe murderball
no i didn't they roll around in their
chairs
all right this is the monday morning
podcast
for august 13th i got one more day on my
project here
i'm doing here i i i let the cat out of
the bag
and i told them that i was going to be
uh i'm working on the
pilot for the reboot of that kids show
zoom
remember that show do you know how that
show used to go
that was a song in the 70s come on give
it a
[Music]
we're going to show you just why we're
going to teach you to fly high it was a
drug reference
that whole thing was take drugs come on
give it a try
we're going to show you just why
why i don't want to do lsd come on give
it a try
i i don't know about come on we're going
to show you why just take the [ __ ]
we're going to teach you to fly hi and
everybody had the same striped shirts on
we're doing a reboot of that without the
drugs
um all right so anyways i'm staying here
in the north end
of boston and i got to tell you
something the italianos make the best
[ __ ] food out there
bar none go [ __ ] yourselves i don't want
to hear it if you're into thai food
or you like scottish [ __ ] uh what
does scottish people eat nini what the
[ __ ]
what is it haggis yeah
what was it that's that's like what
that's like shetland sheepdog balls with
uh some bangers
in the mash there um by the way when i
talk about uh
great britain i should state that like
uh scotland is less than thrilled to be
part of it that was the vibe i got
when i was over there this is really
just my ignorant travel channel show
this time isn't it
um so anyways we've been staying here in
the north end
and uh all i've been doing is eating
italian food i'm having a great time but
as of last night i was finally [ __ ]
sick of it when i had some gnocchi
which is basically potatoes with
wallpaper paste
and a little bit of uh was it pesto
that they put on there you know i'd have
something [ __ ] irish
but um i never used to come over to the
north end
you leaving nia okay bye bye
just like i said to that old lady in the
wheelchair bye bye
bye bye um
what a sport i actually woke her up and
kicked her out of the hotel room so i
could do this
you know hey if you want to come back
later i have another microphone if you
want to do the final [ __ ] 10 minutes
i know people are dying to know what's
going on in your life
i thought you want to slam the door on
me that would have been great
a nod to jim norton um
anyway so we've been hanging out here uh
i got [ __ ] octopus coming out my
[ __ ] ears
no i've eaten way too much italian food
even though i i love it
i'm done okay i've had [ __ ]
tortellini
i've had fettuccine i've had [ __ ]
spaghetti reedy
about everything i had a ragoo
um that went right [ __ ] through me
i wish it would be great if there was a
website
that had a picture of a bunch of
people's different faces when they ate
something that
that that moment when they realized it's
going right through them and they
realize that they're in a public place
it's going to get ugly and they're doing
the math
on how far away the nearest private
toilet that they know
is versus how bad that feeling is in
your gut
um let's just say i wrapped it up pretty
damn quick with the person i was with
[Music]
anyways and then they had some big uh
festival down here
some sort of religious thing where they
had a picture of they had like mary and
everyone was putting dollars on her i
don't know what the hell that one is
i felt like i was in some sort of
scorsese movie
um and then they were playing this frank
sinatra music which is just
it's just the best music ever it just
makes you feel like you you're a [ __ ]
millionaire
you know they started playing the summer
one you know the summer wind
it came blowing in from across
the sea right and of course it sounded
amazing and then for some stupid [ __ ]
reason
they just right as i'm hearing the
beginning of that song
you know that [ __ ] little keyboard
starts playing
and then the little [ __ ] hits with
the horns and you're already swaying as
you're walking down the street i'm
walking towards it right just mesmerized
and all of a sudden this [ __ ]
attitude voice starts singing with it
and i realized they're doing sinatra
like karaoke
and it was some little girl going up
there and she was so [ __ ]
flat and off i i couldn't
and i like it was like frank's singing
like the summer when
k blowing in and she's on top of that
with her [ __ ] eight-year-old
high-pitched voice across the sea
i can't even do it my voice is shot and
i was like immediately
turned in the other direction and i was
trying to get out away from it but the
way the north end is set up with all the
streets diagonal and all the buildings
close together it was just echoing down
all the streets and i couldn't [ __ ]
get away with it
so i had to go up [ __ ] causeway
street
right past the bridge that goes over the
[ __ ] charlestown
that you saw in the movie the town and i
walked up to uh
i walked up to the garden boston garden
and i looked at the bobby orr statue
and uh i got to admit from the side it
looks like bobby orr but when you look
at the face
it looks like that bit i used to do
where remember the old man face bit for
my last special
do you well do you that's what it looked
like i don't know what it is about those
[ __ ] statues they can get everything
to look like the guy except for the face
you know the magic johnson statue
doesn't look like him
the bobby orr statue doesn't look like
him the michael jordan statue just
doesn't look like him even with the
tongue sticking out
it's uh i don't know what it is they
they can't make the face
they can't get the face right really
bill is is this is this the level of
[ __ ]
you know [ __ ] that you think is
interesting to us oh go [ __ ] yourselves
all right let's do a little bit of uh
let's get to a dilemma here
no wait wait i got some other stuff to
talk about first um
before i forget yeah i took uh we
actually took a water taxi
um you know i wanted to surprise nia
we're going on the water taxi
and women are so [ __ ] intuitive
one of the hardest things to ever do is
to surprise a woman
the second you start thinking
god i hope she doesn't notice god i hope
she doesn't [ __ ]
ask me x y and z it's like they sense it
they're like [ __ ] dogs they just pick
it up and be like
what's wrong what's going on nothing why
are you yelling at me
what's going on freaking i was gonna
[ __ ] surprise you with this [ __ ]
boat ride
well you don't have to yell
they run real like i don't understand
why
every interrogator on the first 48 isn't
a [ __ ] woman
their ability that's
that's one of those things that nature
gave him because
nature knew right
nature knew that [ __ ] any nature he
knew
that um that guys could just beat the
[ __ ] out of women
and there were no laws in place you know
back in the day
just whatever you wanted to do you know
if she gave you a rough time
you just balled up your big [ __ ]
caveman fist
hairy knuckles and all and you [ __ ]
cracked her right in the [ __ ] nose
and it bled all over her woolly mammoth
two-piece that she was wearing
and that was the end of the discussion
so
you know they had to adapt
so [ __ ] mother nature gave him this
[ __ ]
i swear to god i can't get away with
it isn't possible to surprise
nia i just it's i can't [ __ ] it it
drives me nuts
i don't understand why there's not more
women in the world series of poker
all right bill we get it they can pick
up what you're doing that's what i'm
saying
so i was sitting there trying i [ __ ]
finally just stopped
and i said will you stop [ __ ] up this
surprise
and then she just laughed you know
probably because it made her feel more
secure right
well good that's good to know that i can
tell when he's [ __ ] acting weird so
if he ever did try to be deceitful
i would be able to pick up on it you
know what i mean
[ __ ] it maniacs so anyway so i take her
on this water taxi right i bring her
over to
one of these little fancy [ __ ] fufu
stores where they you know they go
walking in
where they have the lady gaga wear and
the [ __ ] uh who's another one of the
[ __ ] that they all
think is just amazing fashion sense
did you see the meat dress oh my god not
the meat dress they obviously don't like
that but they like that [ __ ]
veil in the face [ __ ] don't they
don't they all isn't it fair to just
lump them all into one category and then
just say something ignorant
i think it is i think that's totally
fair so anyways we're riding over on the
water taxi and it's [ __ ] tremendous
you know the guy driving it's an ex
[ __ ]
fishing boat captain so he's loving life
you know he's got this great job he
doesn't have any crew
that he has to deal with he doesn't have
to go out of the harbor
you know he just gets to cruise around
on this little boat so he's in a great
mood
you know he's making neil laugh and he's
breaking my balls where you taking her
oh make sure he gets you something
expensive blah blah blah and all that
[ __ ] we're having a great [ __ ] time
so as we're going over there right all
i'm doing is uh
and by the way if i ever had a boat
that's all i would do i would just go
around the harbor there's no way i would
ever go out to sea
i am unbelie i'm terrified did you see
that [ __ ] video of that guy just
sitting in the ocean and that hammerhead
shark just
circling around him before they fished
him out
you know what i don't get i don't get
why
i can't just be in the ocean treading
water
like why that just immediately makes
sharks go oh what the [ __ ] is that
i'm not bleeding i'm swimming just like
a fish
why are you so goddamn [ __ ]
interested in me
why are you [ __ ] 20 miles away going
oh
i i sense a pair of alabaster [ __ ]
legs in the water
i think i'm gonna go over here and take
a bite out of them see how they taste
and then spin back around again if i
like the way it tastes i'm gonna come
back and kill it
i just don't understand that i could see
if you were dead you know
and then you know they're like the
garbage disposals of the ocean they come
by and they [ __ ] eat you but if i'm
totally
fine what is their [ __ ] problem
there's plenty of fish in the sea right
why you got to come at me what am i
doing i'm treading water
i know i don't belong here
that's just they're [ __ ] annoying
another thing
and another thing oh [ __ ] i'm on a
[ __ ] run a little [ __ ] rant here
um
which i'm not by the way i hate how
everything's defined as a [ __ ] rant
you know he everything's a [ __ ]
everything's awkward or it's a [ __ ]
rant it isn't a rant
is to me is absolutely you're you've
completely
lost your [ __ ] you're screaming this
[ __ ]
goddamn foam at the corner of your mouth
that's a [ __ ] rant
going on some little clever little
[ __ ] 45 second run
is not a rant all right you dumb [ __ ]
on the internet can we clear that up and
can we also clear up that the comic does
not heckle the crowd
i know i brought this up but it's
becoming
people keep saying that i loved when you
heckled the crowd no i'm on stage
when you're giving the performance you
can't heckle the crowd
heck a heckler is someone who disrupts a
performance
if you're the guy on stage am i
disrupting the crowd's performance
you're not given one
sorry um
yeah it's [ __ ] shark week on the
discovery channel and
i don't know if anybody who works at the
discovery channel listens to this
podcast
all right but you guys are so [ __ ]
irresponsible over there
okay you do all this [ __ ] when you
talk about sharks about how [ __ ]
horribly they're misunderstood
you know and the beauty of of the
species and all this type of stuff
but you always sell it with that jaws
vibe
you know what i mean it's like it's
literally
it's like fish [ __ ] racism
like the way that they show sharks on
the discovery channel
is the way they showed black people in
the news when i was growing up
[Laughter]
they did everything but played the jaws
music
back in the day and they're still doing
it to sharks
all right and i want to know where are
all the african-americans when it comes
to this [ __ ]
you know why don't why don't you [ __ ]
reach out and have a little bit of
[ __ ] empathy
you can't see you can't see the parallel
uh the
the [ __ ] cross-pollination whatever
the [ __ ] you call it
i don't say it all i'm saying is i
[ __ ] hate the way they do that
where they sit there and they
they uh
they make it they make the shark out to
be like
it's beyond instinct what it's doing
like it's sitting there rubbing its fins
together thinking about [ __ ] sinister
stuff to do
okay it's hungry it's getting something
to eat
you're a dumb [ __ ] you're in the ocean
right
i still don't get why if i'm just
[ __ ] treading water why do you have
to come over and take a bite out of my
leg
leave me alone i [ __ ] hate it i gotta
tell you something when i was i was
sitting there waiting for that water
taxi
just looking into that [ __ ] black
water
you know you can't see you can't even
see below the surface
i said to me i go you couldn't pay me a
million dollars to jump in that [ __ ]
water right now right there
and immediately jump jump right back out
i wouldn't do it and she goes you know
what you're an [ __ ] she goes i'm
gonna go [ __ ] jump in it
just to show you how ridiculous you're
being she goes there's no shark in there
and i was like you know what or maybe
there is
did you see that [ __ ] those people
fishing off their back porch they caught
that fish and all of a sudden a shark
came out of nowhere
ugh they fight i just i [ __ ] hate the
ocean
so anyways so we're on this [ __ ] boat
and we're going by all these goddamn uh
all these giant [ __ ] yachts like
50 million dollar boats parked out in
the harbor and i just really realized
like that whole like the level of
wealth that is out there a 50 million
dollar
boat a boat a hobby
something you just got sitting in the
[ __ ] harbor that maybe you're going
to take out once or twice in a month
was 50 million dollars give me a [ __ ]
break
i mean if i had if i had a 50 million
dollar boat there's no [ __ ] way i
wouldn't be selling drugs
i would just do it because it would be
so goddamn easy
i would just get a brick of [ __ ]
cocaine and i would just [ __ ]
put it on my boat and i would just drive
up the goddamn coast
and i'd drop it off to somebody i'd get
some money and then i would
make a payment on the boat no wait
i got to clean the money ah jesus
i get caught all right strike that i
would be the guy driving
i wouldn't drive the boat because i'm
afraid of the ocean you know what [ __ ]
yutz
okay let's get a little [ __ ]
advertising here for the week
um what do we got here where is it
what did i do with it
all right here we go advertisement
number one
um all right mandatory intro
why do i always do that um okay hey
you've probably heard about
legalzoom.com but now i'm telling you
about
them so you got to check them out these
guys are great
um all right if you've been wanting
you've been waiting for the perfect time
to start your dream business
it's right now incorporate your business
or form an llc at legalzoom.com
starting at just 99 bucks i paid 1500
i paid 1500 you can do it for 99 bucks
and if you have a family guess what you
need to make sure they're protected
you can protect your family and assets
with legal zoom
with a legal zoom will for just 69
look at this set your whole life up
you're still under 200 bucks here
in the past 12 years over 2 million
americans have used legalzoom
for llc's wills trusts trademarks come
up with an invention
you don't want somebody to steal it or
when they do steal it you want to be
able to sue them
and then come you know settle out of
court and then you get a yacht and then
you're doing your thing
you can even trademarks and more
they've saved hundreds even thousands of
dollars versus going to a traditional
lawyer
legalzoom's online process guides you
step by step
and you get total customer support
support it couldn't be much easier they
even have attorneys
an attorney to help you if you need to
get through their legal plans
um start your business and protect your
family today at legalzoom.com you also
get a special discount from listening to
the
this podcast make sure you enter bur
b-u-r-r
in the referral box and at checkout for
more savings legalzoom is not a law firm
and self-help services are provided at
your
uh your direction there you go
all right that was painless wasn't it
you know i actually have to get a will
done and i have i have been putting that
off
because i'm superstitious when it comes
to that i feel like if i
start to write a will that means uh i'm
saying to the universe like all right
tapping out
i've had enough but um
i'm actually i got inspired to do it
uh this past week a uh one of my
relatives passed away unfortunately and
had to go to the funeral but this person
had it all worked out
right down to their outro song
and i underrated picking the music for
your funeral
as morbid as that is you got to realize
we're all going to go
someday and uh
this funeral was was [ __ ] awesome it
was
it was a celebration of a life and there
was way more laughing than crying
and i think a lot of that had to do with
the music
[ __ ] outro music wheeling out of the
church
uh when the saints go marching in was
this person's favorite song and and it
was it was
it was the [ __ ] and i really got
inspired i was sitting there going
what the hell would i what what's it
seems like you know old people's like
their their music is appropriate
it's such great music that it's
appropriate for any situation
and i'm really trying to think like of
the music that i listen to
you know all that heavy metal and
[ __ ] zeppelin and ac dc
i mean i can't have any ac dc playing as
i'm wheeled out half of that's about the
devil and going to hell
i don't want to put that out there
didn't have those three things from
ghost come up
remember that [ __ ] and drag me down um
but i'm telling you underrated so i want
to know from you guys
all right when you kick the bucket tell
me about how you're going to do your
funeral
how would you like it to be done and
uh outro music and all that type of [ __ ]
what are you gonna do you're gonna be go
in the box you're gonna get cremated
this is [ __ ] up huh you gotta make
these decisions
and if you need to make a will go to
legalzoom.com bam there you go
in and out right there all right what
else happened this week in the world
of sports uh dwight howard went to the
lakers an absolute
shocker an absolute shocker that yet
another guy who couldn't win a
championship
somewhere else is now going to go pile
on with the lakers
it's ridiculous it's they have literally
become the new york yankees
of the nba every [ __ ] year
they do this and i want kobe bryant to
start getting some [ __ ] for this
if you're gonna give [ __ ] lebron
james [ __ ] for pilate for leaving
cleveland
and pile on piling on in miami then god
damn it kobe has had people [ __ ]
coming to him
for his entire goddamn career 15 [ __ ]
years in a row
and they got the nerve to sit there and
compare this guy to jordan
look at the [ __ ] teams this guy has
been on and go back and look at those
chicago bulls teams and i want to i want
you to start telling me
dennis rodman is the only [ __ ]
like free agent that i can really
remember that they signed
all right and he was there was one
[ __ ] guy
kobe gets two three guys every year oh
it's ridiculous
it's absolutely ridiculous i'm telling
you as a crabby
old man these are not your father's
championships these are not championship
teams these there's no difference
between these championship teams
and that rich kid whose first car is
like a [ __ ]
goddamn maserati because his dad is rich
all right you know what's so [ __ ] up
about these teams
and i include the 2008 celtics in this
that was a that was a bought and paid
for championship
i know they put the work in i know all
of that but it's not the [ __ ] same
this is the funny thing about these
pylon teams is i remember as a kid
when you'd be out outside at recess and
they'd we'd start picking teams
if they got too lopsided kids would be
oh oh wait a minute that's not fair they
would people flip out
and they'd break up the teams and you'd
balance it out where i was from they was
called
smuk teams i don't even know where that
came from
these are smug teams these teams are
smuck which meant it was [ __ ]
you had shaq and kobe and all these
[ __ ] guys on one team was gonna be a
goddamn bloodbath
all right and even it's like second and
third graders we understood
how [ __ ] pointless it was to then go
out and play the game
if you had all the most talented people
on one [ __ ] team
right so we broke it up and we would we
would have it evened out and we'd have a
great game during [ __ ] recess now if
we can understand that
why can't full-grown adults understand
that
in these leagues and professional
leagues why can't they understand that
all right but if that's the way it is i
accept it
i accept these pylon championships but i
want them to be called that
all right the same way they had the dead
ball and then the live ball error
these [ __ ] laker championships
celtics championships
miami championships these are not the
same as the ones in the 80s
right through the [ __ ] chicago bulls
i would even say the spurs
you know the the david robinson uh
tim duncan once like i don't want to
hear it
don't [ __ ] be talking about don't
bring up larry
and magic and all these other guys with
the guys of today it's different
okay because just imagine back in the
day if bird
magic just piled on and got on the same
[ __ ] team
like why is that enjoyable
i gotta be honest with you that first
dream team
i didn't even watch it i didn't want to
watch
[ __ ] larry bird magic johnson
akeem elijah wan charles barkley
go play rwanda you know what i mean what
am i gonna do next what and then what
watch me
go play a game of wiffle ball with some
[ __ ] second graders like i don't
understand what where what is the thrill
in that and if you're of in one of those
cities and you're getting all these guys
and you're [ __ ] psyched and you don't
give a [ __ ]
um that's because you don't understand
you don't you don't even understand
sports
you and you're the same kind of person
that i be i bet cannot be swayed in an
argument
even if somebody makes a good [ __ ]
point because all you want to do is be
right you just want to win like that fox
news kind of
uh like debating style
where it's all good if you agree with me
and if you don't agree with me i'm just
going to yell at you and cut out your
mic and that's going to be the [ __ ]
debate
um it sucks okay so now i'm down to two
sports now
football and hockey because you can't do
that in either one of those sports
because they have a hard cap
i know people say in baseball they have
a hard cap yeah well they have
a loophole that you can drive a 200
million dollar team through
called the luxury tax you can just
basically pay it off
and you can go out and buy everybody on
the [ __ ] planet so i don't know
i don't know i got to find some
different sports to take place of of
hoop
and [ __ ] baseball because i'm done
with both of those sports until they
they they just [ __ ] you know how
i don't it's it's [ __ ] stupid you
know what it is
about those teams why i don't respect
them because
it takes more money than brain cells to
put those [ __ ] teams together
back in the day you needed brain cells
you had to like break down
people you had to try to see stuff
before other people saw it now you just
go
hey we need a center who's the best guy
available what's he being offered offer
him 10 million more next problem i could
[ __ ] do that
by the bottomless pit of cash that's
[ __ ] it's depressing
it's depressing so i don't know but i
still don't think the lakers have the
coach
and i know goddamn well kobe bryant
doesn't [ __ ] respect him you know
when you're doing great in the game and
the coach goes to high-five you and you
completely ignore him
i would say that that's a complete lack
of respect what do you think huh am i
crazy to think that
am i crazy
all right e-voice everybody here we go
here's another way to start up if you're
going to start up your business
i'm slowly getting advertising here that
suddenly is going to get you out of your
cubicle
all right e-voice your mobile phone at
work
uh one of the great e-voice features is
call recording it's easy to use
all you have to do is press uh star 2
to start a stop recordings during any
incoming or outgoing call
basically what what e-voice is is you
have these
what are they calling viral viral uh
phone numbers
you can basically with your cell phone
get you know
like three four other phone numbers and
it just will ring to your own damn phone
no one has to know what your real phone
number is it's a great way to be at work
and actually have a private business
going on so you can just you know
rather than having to save up your
trinkets at your cubicle job
you don't have to start from square one
to start your new business you can be
you can actually be sitting in your
cubicle
taking business calls for your own
business without those bosses knowing
about it it's phenomenal
um anyways the file is then saved
as an mp uh on a wav file and you can
store it on your computer to refer back
to later at a later date if need be
um all right call recording from e-voice
is perfect for doctors lawyers real
estate agents hiring managers or any
professional discussing contracts
if it's even great if you just don't
have a pen
handy or you're in the car driving and
can't write something down
other e-voice features include call
forwarding music on hold
voice mail to text toll-free numbers
and 800 numbers for a free six months
trial go to www.evoice.com
bill burr or go to the banner on my
podcast page at billboard.com
um yeah it's phenomenal you can have
conference calls
with up to 90 people it's just a great
and they actually have like professional
uh
voice actors that will uh you know give
you some little uh
fancy outgoing message you know so it
actually sounds like you have an office
when you don't
it's phenomenal e-voice everybody go
check it out
all right back to the podcast um
all right what do we got here let's get
it let's get on with the lemmas here
the lemmage okay hey bill would you
rather have as many gold medals as
michael phelps
or as many super bowl rings as joe
montana
uh well do i get to be joe montana
seeing that and that's that that little
uh dilemma i don't know if i'm joe
montana
if i'm going to have as many rings as
joe montana i want to be joe montana or
jerry rice
i want to be somebody that they remember
i don't want to be the [ __ ] left
tackle
you know protecting the blind side or
whatever the [ __ ] going on there right
i don't be that guy
i want to be somebody that somebody
remembers ronnie lott
or be michael phelps
um that's a good one because you know
what sucks about being michael phelps is
like
he's kind of done at 24. you know he's
gonna come back at 28 and not quite be
as fast
those sports where you just finished at
24 like tennis um
i don't know michael phelps
but football's such a man's sport but
you can't walk when you're 40.
although i saw joe montana in an
restaurant he still looked great
uh [ __ ] that i'd rather win super bowls
i'd rather win super bowls there you go
all right dearest billiam
i am friends with a lot of people who
have a lot of delusional hobbies
throughout the last couple of years i've
had to attend their shitty band
shows the shows for their shitty bands
to make that a little more clearer
or go to their plays i've even been
asked to donate money for the cost of
making a cd
and solicited to donate to a buddy's
short film so he could make it
well it sounds like you have a lot of
motivated friends here
what are you you are you the hater
maybe he's right let's let's read the
rest of this before i judge him i repeat
a
short film well i made a short film with
the teen idol sensation joe derosa
and robert kelly who's on a new [ __ ]
tv
show called the bronx crew or something
like that on
fx like no joke he's like the lead
um in a goddamn tv show bobby
huh you know how great it is to see that
for him
i've watched that man for 20 years on
stand-up doing stand-up
doing plays and all that type of [ __ ]
and he hung in there and he kept
swinging he put his [ __ ] head down
and bang look at that
it's [ __ ] phenomenal anyways all all
of this wouldn't be so bad
yeah we made a short film and got into
the tribeca film festival
you know joe derosa is now on his way to
having a little burgeoning like uh
directing career
all right don't knock a short film sir
you have no idea where this could go
anyways he goes oh this wouldn't be so
bad if all of their stupid hobby
hobbies didn't always end up costing me
at least 40 bucks
from donations to cover charges at the
gig
they're playing etc the most recent one
is a friends improv class showcase where
i get to watch a bunch of amateurs put
on a show
with a two drink minimum and ticket
costs exactly what i want to do with my
free time
now my question is can i just start a
blanket policy of not going to any more
of these
and not donating without coming off like
a complete dick
i want to make the improv show my last
event
then never support the hobbies of my
untalented friends
that constantly piss my money away to
put it bluntly my friend's events aren't
exactly the same as
you going to support dane cook and the
producers he probably had the decency to
comp your ticket
and any help is greatly appreciated well
dude what you have to understand is that
dane didn't start off doing
starring in the producers at the
hollywood bowl we did open mics and
shitty restaurants
and we had to learn how to do stand-up
look if you're always having to go to
these things i understand
that but um
you know you know something
i wouldn't want you to come to my show
if i was starting out
you just seem really like annoyed by the
whole thing you're gonna have a negative
vibe
and i just would feel like i would be on
stage as i'm trying to learn how to do
stand-up and i would look out at you and
you would have like your eyebrows up
like gee you know like
are you done yet really you thought that
was funny
you know you wouldn't even be smiling
you'd just be staring at me like was
that the last one can i go now
can i leave um sir it sounds to me like
you need a hobby
all right you need more of a social life
and uh then you wouldn't have time to go
to all your friends
um i don't know plays and all this i
find it weird that you don't do any of
this [ __ ]
you know that you have people making
short films you know people in bands and
you know people in improv
classes you're kind of spanning the
performance
uh rainbow there yet do you perform
do you want to perform why aren't you a
performer if you hang out with all these
performers
i don't understand what's going on with
you sir did you go to some
high school for the gifted and by the
time you realized that you weren't
gifted it was too late you just stayed
there
so now you're going to school with all
these future fiona apples and all that
type of [ __ ] you're going to watch them
play an acoustic set at the corner of
some subway franchise and you've had it
i don't know what it is sir but you know
what be your own goddamn man
just say listen i don't [ __ ] want to
go to any of your [ __ ] anymore
all right i don't have the money or the
time i would rather see the completed
call me when you make it and give me a
free ticket and then you can be the guy
when they do
the uh the early days you'll be that guy
you know you'll be in one of those
documentaries where nobody from the band
that's always like a major red flag when
they're doing a documentary on
a person like an actor or a band
or an athlete and that person
the person the subject isn't in the
documentary and neither are any of the
person's immediate friends
and then they always go to a guy like
this guy like yeah i used to [ __ ]
uh i used to see him go on in front of
[ __ ] two people
you'll end up being that guy you know
well this is the thing sir if any of
those people make it you better not be
that douche who said i always believed
in you
because you don't believe in these
people on any [ __ ] level
so uh i i would start
i would just [ __ ] make sure you had
other plans
that's the easiest way to go if you want
to be nice and not hurt their feelings
or you could just [ __ ] come right out
with it just be like listen
i've seen you improv before um i'm going
to wait six months and let
maybe you'll get much better at it and
it'll be entertaining for me
okay i'm gonna go to a bar and go hit on
a girl that's how i want to improv
because i don't know what i'm gonna say
either okay i'll throw out a subject
me [ __ ] that girl over there go [ __ ]
yourself i'm out
how about that all right next one bill
should i have kids
how the [ __ ] you supposed to know if you
should have kids or not neither my wife
nor i have strong feelings either way
and we are getting to that age where it
stops making sense
so we need to make a decision and live
with it
um yeah if you're not feeling it don't
do it
there's plenty of [ __ ] kids there's
plenty of kids to go out and adopt
you know if you realize later that oh
maybe i wanted a kid
well what age would have my kid been if
i had one probably about eight yeah let
me get an eight-year-old
let me get uh let me get two
eight-year-olds and a [ __ ] seven and
uh throw in the 11.
there we go then you have a [ __ ] big
brady bunch family
there's plenty of kids out there that
need to be adopted and uh there's too
many [ __ ] people on the planet and
we're running out of natural resources
and uh my
belief is that the population problem is
going to be handled
like a [ __ ] term paper you know the
same way we handled y2k
at the last [ __ ] second and when you
do [ __ ] at the last [ __ ] second
it's gonna be a rash [ __ ]
quick decisions which means there's
gonna be uh
some sort of final solution going on i
really believe that we are rapidly
headed towards that
you know if they don't i mean we have
seven billion people on the planet and
and there's no politician going hey
you know why don't you just [ __ ] not
have kids for a minute
or if you're not really feeling it or
we'll give you some money not to have
kids
it's [ __ ] insane
i don't know we're running out of
chicken in [ __ ] soup
uh all right that didn't even make sense
all right cheating hey bill
um word on the street is you're the male
version of oprah
so hear me out you know that's actually
insulting
to oprah all right um i've got this lady
i'm fooling around with now and then
she has a boyfriend but doesn't seem to
mind hooking up with me
when i ask her to yeah that chick's a
[ __ ] nightmare dude
uh before we even go you're not gonna
have a relationship with her
if she cheats on someone she'll end up
cheating on you and every time you [ __ ]
her you're risking
one of these times that boyfriend's
gonna find out and he might show up with
a tire iron
and uh you know remodel your face
anyways when we met she never wants to
go further than second base
saying that would be cheating um
last night i went to her house to pick
her up for a party
dude there's not another woman out there
that you could pick up for a party
what are you doing dude do you want to
be that guy do you want to be the guy
who [ __ ] plays with the tits of some
[ __ ] broad that has a boyfriend
come on uh there's nothing makes a guy
weaker
than uh [ __ ] easy [ __ ]
easy [ __ ] has brought down more goddamn
men
the layup piece of ass
um because we're lazy anyways before we
made it
and when i say we're lazy i mean human
beings in general all right ladies
before you [ __ ] pat yourself on the
back and make your tits shake
um last night i went to her house to
pick her up for a party
uh before we made it in the in the car
i had her up against my car we were
making out
like world war ii ended i then suggested
suggestively open the door to the back
seat
but instead of entering she asked me if
i
loved her or if i just wanted sex yeah
dude this girl's crazy
i neither confirmed nor denied either of
those questions
yeah that's stupid that's a great lie
that's great all right this is just
straight across the this is a linear
story
begins with deceit goes into the seat
and it's going to end with it
um i just went back to kissing her
after she got drunk at the party ah
jesus
nah and you're sitting there like a
[ __ ] wolf waiting for her to get
hammered
uh we talked again and she said she was
willing to dump her boyfriend and have
sex
with me if i just told her that i love
her
and want to be with her i actually don't
but i really want to bang this chick
i was thinking about just saying i love
her and then dumping her after we banged
but i guess that would be kind of a dick
move yeah it would be
but i got it we got everybody's got to
take responsibility for their actions
this [ __ ] woman is setting herself up
for this [ __ ]
my morris [ __ ] my moral compass has no
needle
needle bill help me out greetings from
belgium
uh i hope you were able to read that
fluently as you always do look at this
guy
[ __ ] sarcastic in a second language
um yeah
listen uh you know do you really want to
be this guy
that's that's if you believe in karma
that's a really bad thing to do
all right you're being lazy
okay this girl's obviously damaged
there's something wrong with her
and um if you do what you're thinking of
doing just so you can bang her you're
really going to devastate her and
is it worth devastating another human
being
just to get just a to [ __ ] banger
here's one for you
this is classic all right this is uh
not my advice this is standard advice
okay
here's the deal why don't you rub one
out to her and afterwards
immediately think do i really think
about what you're doing and the way
you're going to
be getting this girl and ask yourself if
you really want to do it
all right and then act accordingly and
if you still want to do
it please don't ever get a job in a
corporation
because you will move up that ladder in
20 seconds oh my god he's a sociopath he
has no feelings he doesn't care about
people
let's give him a corner office um
okay ex porn star or something ex porn
is all it says dear bill i'm a 22 year
old lady
seeking some valuable male insight and
perspective
i've been dating my boyfriend for over a
year now and everything's been
incredible well congratulations i
i have no feeling that this is going to
go in a different direction
anyways we felt like soul mates
and didn't like to be apart however all
of a sudden he became very distant
towards me i tried to ignore it
justifying it with some personal issue
he was dealing with
little did i know those personal issues
also involved me
and his ex
feeling a horribly familiar sense
infidelity deja vu i think you skipped a
word in there
i did something awful i could kick
myself in the face for i looked through
his laptop
i know it's a really dis despicably dick
thing to do
but i needed some strand of truth even
if it would break my heart
got to tell you something
if he was being a good guy and you did
that
you know that's a piece of [ __ ] thing to
do
and the fact that he was giving you the
i'm cheating on you
vibe and you still felt like a piece of
[ __ ] by
going through his emails you're a good
person you're being too hard on yourself
um what are you supposed to be you know
that person in good fellas who's content
to be a jerk what am i supposed to say
that my boyfriend cheats on me
see how i switched it up for you anyways
i read an email he wrote to his
ex-girlfriend expressing his lament
about being with the wrong person
well there you go it's over game set and
match
it went and went on about how amazing
she was
and how any other girl me would only
ever be second best
this prompted me to look through his
photos and i found some recently opened
but only nude pictures of her this hit
me really hard because
unlike regular porn nude pictures of x's
hold something sentimental value
i don't appreciate or think it's is
appropriate
well that's about as lightly as you can
put it
um yeah you should definitely not
appreciate that he actually knows that
woman and
banged her uh
putting myself in this conundrum i
couldn't bring this sensitive topic up
without admitting i
invaded his private invaded his privacy
although my hunch was right
i know i was wrong in looking through
his personal [ __ ] but is it wrong of him
to still masturbate to naked pictures of
his ex
even after he reassured me he had
deleted them
how would i go about talking to him
about this or is this situation better
left
undiscussed now that we are on better or
closer terms i appreciate any piece of
advice
or opinion greatly so uh go [ __ ]
yourself question mark
uh
i you know i don't know what
i can't even [ __ ] answer this what he
gave me the vibe like he was [ __ ]
around on you and he is
he is [ __ ] around on you
and that whole thing about that your
your your second best go
[ __ ] yourself [ __ ] that break up with
the guy
alright you know what your biggest
problem is
sweetheart is you are a sweetheart
and this guy is at the very least a
confused uh
he's a [ __ ] dirtbag he's not being
honest with you okay now this is the
thing about
if you're a sweetheart in life male or
female
pieces of [ __ ] gravitate towards you
they need a sweetheart in their life to
put up with
their piece of [ __ ] behavior so what you
have to learn to do
that if you are a sweetheart be a big
hearted person
you have to be guarded all right and you
have to make somebody earn
the fact that you're a sweetheart you
just don't give it away
all right because when you're just
giving it away and you're [ __ ] nice
to hey how are you i just met you will
you help me move
okay that's the nice thing you're gonna
get taken advantage of
so this guy's taking advantage of you
[ __ ] this guy
break up with him okay if he wasn't such
a [ __ ] shifty
piece of [ __ ] you wouldn't have to done
that piece of [ __ ] thing he basically
gave you grounds for a warrant to go
search through his [ __ ]
all right and you were right okay
although you didn't get a warrant you
kind of did it like the robe cop who now
has to throw his badge on the desk yet
still go out and solve the [ __ ] crime
like all those 80
cop buddy movies but you were right you
deserve better
[ __ ] this guy all right you should break
up with him even though it's gonna hurt
um all right so you know what i think
that that's gonna be the podcast for
this week a little under an hour i know
that's shorter than what you're used to
but um i gotta i gotta upload this and
send it to my guy to give to you guys
that you're now listening to and by the
way
i was on did you guys check out breaking
bad i was on breaking bad last week
uh last night and everything i didn't
get a chance to watch it
um but uh it's always weird
watching yourself anyways but i love
that show so i have to uh
i'm actually two episodes behind but uh
i peeked at my twitter and i got
nothing but positive things thank god
thank god so i appreciate everybody
saying that because you know
this acting stuff is new to me all right
so all the compliments you gave me
really makes up for the fact that you
break my balls about my podcast every
week so thank you
to anybody who wrote something nice on
twitter that really made me feel good
and uh and go [ __ ] yourself to all the
people who are now going to write mean
[ __ ] because it's funny which it is
but i don't care uh the the honest
reviews already came in so have at it
have a good time trashing me i don't
give a [ __ ]
um that's the podcast for this week by
the way
i'm gonna be down nantucket wednesday
night
i have a show wednesday night uh
down in nantucket there's still tickets
left it's gonna be a great show where i
uh basically performed to uh
like fishermen in the [ __ ] illuminati
it's gonna be a really interesting mix
of people
and uh i'm really excited to go down
there uh beautiful beautiful
island off the coast of massachusetts
and what else do i got
you guys want to hear some of my other
upcoming dates before i bring this
mercifully to an end
uh what do i got oh jesus bill why don't
you have things ready why don't you have
things ready
um i'm going to be at the orlando improv
beginning on september 7th on then on
the 8th and on the 9th i've never been
there before
and i got caroline's on broadway new
york city rescheduled that from the one
that i
moved from july it's going to be
september 20th 21st 22nd and 23rd
um and that's it other than uh
what do we got here oh jesus
hang in there for a second i got one
other thing that i want to tell you
about
and that would be oh here it is
here it is real quick amazon.com people
if you want to support this podcast and
the wounded
warriors project just go on to the
podcast page on billboard.com
click on the banner ad the amazon banner
ad then go to amazon and buy something
you don't have to do anything else once
you get to amazon
if you buy something amazon kicks me a
little bit of money and i throw
10 to the wounded warrior project um and
gamefly.com
um anyways uh thanks for clicking the
gamefly banners for your free two
two disc two week free trial over 40
people did that last month so thank you
very much for that
and hopefully you you enjoyed the
service you enjoyed your 8 000
games that you could try for two free
weeks if you want to be part of those
people who are doing it having a great
time playing video games instead of
paying attention to their significant
others
i mean you want a free two-week trial
you can go to gamefly.com
or the banner ad on my podcast page for
your free trial
free trial and enjoy all the all the
video games you can play
that's it you guys have a great week go
[ __ ] yourselves don't take any [ __ ] and
i'll talk to you next week
you